hello and welcome
to our webinar beyond the basics for
tips
for a successful cyber security career
today
our guest dr microsoft
and showing it from ibm
before we get started a few instructions
on how to navigate webex
the question mark button will let you
put in a question in the q a box we will
collect these
and ask them of our panelists
the q a section of the webinar at the
end
you can use the chat function to send a
message to all panelists
please please do send it to all
panelists that we see it
and we're also going to have one
interactive poll and
that will be right now we're going to
ask
what is your current job role
and we're going to ask how you're
feeling today and we'll take uh we'll
leave the poll open for just a minute or
so
i'd like to get a feeling for who's in
the audience and we'd like to make sure
that uh
everybody's holding up well in this
pandemic era with all the
strange new stresses of life
it's nice to see that most people are
saying uh they're feeling pretty good
and we'll give the poll about 20 seconds
more
to get your answers and hit submit
and three two one
i'll share the poll results here
the greatest number of people that here
today are students
we do have uh managers and executives in
the audience
also cyber security professionals
and as i said most of you are feeling
pretty good today so
i'm glad to hear that and i will
introduce
our panelists
is cloud
engineering at microsoft he's formerly a
director of
cyber security with pwc consulting in
india
um has an extensive knowledge of
security standards and
experience in virtually every aspect
of security assessment and
threat counter measures so
we're lucky to have him and we're lucky
to have sonic
from ibm india who is uh
setting up and running the security
consulting services practice
in india and south asia for ibm
as a senior managing consultant
an expert also in governance and
compliance and information risk
cyber security and data protection
and welcome to you both
thank you so much stuart for inviting us
and
good evening first of all for people who
are joining us from india
and good morning for the people joining
us from the other part of the world as
well and good day for
the people who probably would land in
the afternoon or the mid evening
we are lucky to have uh being hosted
here
on this particular session and would
take an opportunity to thank you all for
joining this first of all
and would love to share my experiences
as well
uh that i have gained over the years
with you as well to
make it more healthy discussions and
would like to have the question and
answers going through
as well over to you sean yeah
thank you thank you for the lovely
introduction thank you everyone thank
you for taking out your time and coming
over this webinar trying to understand
if you can be of any help to you
so thank you to our host gracias host
templar
for organizing this and look forward a
fantastic evening of discussions
thank today um so let's get started with
a
very general question um
and i'll start with uh you process which
is
how has cyber security evolved in the
past few years
and why are companies paying more
attention to it
now than before
so the way i look at this uh steward
over the years traditionally if you
look at we used to be have
a dealings or the conversations in
person we used to visit the marketplace
by the staff and then come back over the
years the businesses
have transformed their i.t systems into
the way they carry out the business
not only regionally but across the globe
so the ecosystem for them
from a consumer perspective have grown
enormous and beyond the boundaries of
a particular region or geography not
only that
it has also kind of i would say blasted
beyond the boundaries when it comes to
third parties that they interact with
the supplier the dealership network
it's all connected now and the moment
you start picking up one thread
you start to realize that the thread is
not
local or is no more concentric to one
particular
event or one particular office rather
it's it's a cross
you can't leave people you can't use
process you can't leave technology and
now
you can't leave the cloud as well or the
virtual ecosystem that we live in
and over the period if you really look
at the way technology has
expanded its footprint it's
mobile nowadays so we have mobile
applications we have
mobile devices i mean technology is
everywhere the cars that we drive
uh even the thermostats that we have
it's all connected ecosystem
so a one breach of one particular area
can really land up into a mess into
other areas as well
and that is where it is now important
for all of us to understand why the
security is at the core of
whatever we do and why it is so
important for
an individual as well leave aside the
organization which is all the more
important for them as well
to take care of their internal
stakeholders of their external
stakeholders
and when it comes to the regulators when
it comes to the government
it is it is all about citizens and it is
all about protecting the
uh the the country's information the
citizens personal information as well so
i mean you can't really think about
anything without the security nowadays
it's it's like protecting your identity
it
it's like protecting what you want to do
and how you do
so it has evolved and it will there to
stay
for long and uh the the threat actors
are really becoming smart day by day uh
like i talked about the automotive
industry as well we can look at the
breaches
that have started to happen and that we
started to see
on the automobile sector it is all about
the connected apps now
beat a can protocol which is a propriety
protocol for
auto segment it's everywhere so it is
important that we stay relevant
we stay informed and we keep ourselves
aware on
the cyber security breaches so that we
can learn from it and grow more into the
areas
of the protection and the response as
well
thank you for us so this is how i look
at it i started my career in 2000
as a network security engineer and
at that point of time my profile was
more of uh
engineering to take care of a solaris
firewall checkpoint firewall
running on solaris at one of the public
service companies of india and the
contract was with the
system integrator in india so it was
more of a network security role that i
had
had at the point of time and my next job
was another
network so what i've seen is that uh the
answer to the question
is the more the ways the more the ways
of data
transmission and movement have changed
cyber security or information security
they also changed
accordingly so we remember the days when
they were the floppy disk
and we used to have this read write
notch on the floppy disk so that was
data protection right i used to
protect my data from being taken away i
used to protect the data
from being written or prevented from
being written
on top of it so that was also one kind
of protection as you can see the floppy
disk is no more
okay pendrives are going away so we used
to have
at one point of time many of our
competitors were on the
digitization and computerization has
enhanced
changed augmented as and when various
computing models have come up i think
when cloud has come up as more of a
business come completely modeled almost
as in when
third parties have come in more into the
picture so
the straight factors have changed and as
invented vectors have changed
that is why cyber security has become
much more holistic
much more comprehensive in nature to
include all the threat factors into
the picture so previously maybe it was
only a part of it like only i t security
or computer security or only network
security
now when you talk of your information
over all
all the channels the cloud the iot the
mobile
the mobile employee the borderless uh
workforce everything everybody
everything is sponsored another complete
of this
so that is how it is expanded with the
expansion or with the discovery and
implementation of new value
computing models and working models
okay the two main
i mean two threats that i picked out of
your responses were
uh the proliferation of applications
and moving things out
into a distributed world and the
proliferat
proliferation of data itself
and the increased
volumes of data transactions
and both of those present more
opportunities
for cyber security threats and dangers
so what are some of the new threat types
that cyber security needs to defend
against
uh would you please bring the my closer
i mean uh
yes uh i was going to say
that's what i picked from your responses
were
the proliferation of applications and
distribution of devices as well as the
increased volume of data and both of
those are
opportunities for greater threats cyber
security
what are the nature of some of the new
threats that are emerging and so like if
you
answered
so partners would you like to go first
i can go for strong so the way i look at
uh from the trends that we are seeing
from
breaches or from an issues perspective
in the cyber area
i think uh with the uh with the pandemic
coming into the play and more and more
adoption of cloud happening
there are breaches which are increasing
on the cloud instances
and when we talk about the storage
buckets the s3 buckets in the cloud when
we talk about the configuration
when we talk about a regulatory or a
security needs
beyond the perimeter of the boundaries i
mean
that's one area where we feel that
the organization would put more focus
because that is what is being targeted
as of now when
we speak uh even if you look at the
trends between 2019 and 2020
we see that uh most of the app-based
services that got briefed is because of
a mis-configurations
on their cloud instances on the s3
bucket
and leave aside that i mean from the
perspective of
the threads we have started to see ai
fuzzing happening into
into the environments wherein it is now
more automated way of detecting
exploiting and then taking actions on
the target
to make sure that we accelerate the zero
days attack
on the iit systems while we can
obviously take an advantage
of the ai fusing to respond to those
breaches as well
but then the similar capabilities are
along with the hackers as well
so we really need to make sure that we
are protecting ourselves
against the ai fussing attacks as well
the third and
uh the most predominant i would say
attack that we have seen over ages and
rather over decades
within the cyber or an iit industry are
the social engineering attacks
and that is where if we really refer to
verizon data breach investigation report
starting from 2015 until date one of the
areas or a threat vector which makes it
to the report
every year and that is called phishing
attack
and we have been hearing about this
phishing attack for long and
uh like sean talked about his journey
within the id
area and the security area uh ever since
that i have been into this
uh this domain for last 15 16 years i
have been hearing about the phishing
but unfortunately we have not been able
to overcome this attack
uh one of the reports from the verizon
data breach investigation report still
refers that it takes six seconds to
click on a phishing
attempt and user getting compromised and
their id systems as well
and the matter is spreading across the
organization
so it's just one click that it takes to
infect the entire id system in the
organization other interesting trend
that i have seen
is uh is on the deep fake
theory and that's that's one concept
which is really
taking up nowadays and specifically with
the elections coming up in different
countries in different parts of the
world
this is one agenda that i see from a
cyber criminal perspective
it's picking up very well uh and which
basically translates to changing the
face
manipulating the audio in a video clip
and then circulating it over a social
platform
and that's for the spreading the false
propaganda
as well so deep fake is picking up and
then
ransomware attacks is is what we have
started to see
from 2015 onwards and there are real
threats
they are here to live for long uh
we have we have talked we have looked
into the wannacry we have looked into
petya
we have looked for the snake bites we
have looked at for
no petya and what not i mean the
ransomwares are real threat
and and the irony is that you don't
really need a technical
uh advancements or the technical
knowledge
to write those codes you can really go
on to the dark web
render hacker for you for as less as 500
and you can get a facebook or a social
platform id hacked for you
you go on to the dark web rent a hacker
for a data breach that you want to
target across
an organization share the details with
them
share the bitcoins with them and you
will have your targeted
attack carried out for you based on
phishing based on smishing
based on wishing attacks all of these
are very very targeted
so i think from a trends perspective we
still see a lot of contributors
from the earlier era while we also see
new contributing new contributing
factors such as the ransomwares
such as ai fuzzing such as cloud
security as top of the agendas as
well for the today's organization what's
your thought showmak on this so part of
your right while you're
fairly covered in the journey of breach
or dental journey of attack vectors
and as we have shown that the attack
vectors have become much more
sophisticated in nature much more
advanced in nature
what remains constant i think is the
human beings
the human beings always continue to
remain at the weakest link
right so uh and fishing is a very much
big evidence and proof of that
so why is fishing still surviving
fishing i think is one of the oldest
surviving
successful methods of hacking or
compromise
and this is possible just because of
humans being the weakest link
we remember this famous attack where a
human being picked up a usb pin drive
outside the
office and then he plugged it into one
of his network computers and then
from bangkok the wider spread all across
the network so it was a combination of
again the human beings being the weakest
link and
uh the usb devices or usb ports not
being secured
adequately and that is how that has
started but if you see as you see
i mean youth reports are now secured
many things are secured
but as long as we human beings do not
abide by basic cyber security hygiene
i mean we'd always proves to be the
weakest link in the
in the entire transaction okay so uh
breaches are becoming more and more
advanced attack vectors are becoming
more and more advanced
more and more devices more and more
system is being used for the attack
but uh i think protection will come up i
mean as and when cloud security is now a
hot topic
uh the cloud because of this
configuration in sql configuration
because of this
posture the cloud may be insecure but
definitely we are having solutions to
secure this
but we even have to have to contribute
to the success of this story by being
protected ourselves
i think that is what i wanted to ask you
for us and i cannot agree more than
more than anything on that show and
study if i can share my experience
one of the experiences that i have been
that i faced while i was working with
verizon
in india for their database
investigation
practice i was leading that and there
was a breeze that happened in pune india
and i flew to that place to contribute
to the investigation
and uh during the investigation we found
that there was a 45 million dollar ease
that happened across the globe for that
organization
it was a global payment processing
organization and they were under
under a targeted breach during the
investigation
we came out with more than 1600 plus
critical issues within the organization
and
those 1600 really if you bifurcate that
observations or the gaps those would
relate to
insecure configurations people not
looking at the monitoring engine
they had all the technologies that that
you know one can think of
on this planet and unfortunately they
did not have skills to look at that
and that kind of resonates back and uh
you know gives me a food for thought
on on the same uh human skills that you
talked about shawn
and not only that the breach if you
really look at how it all started it
started because of a misconfiguration on
one of the tomcat instance
wherein the username and the password
were configured
default as tomcat and tomcat and that's
where the attackers were able to upload
the malicious software
uh upload the keyloggers onto the target
system and they were
able to scan the entire network because
of
the logger and and the functionality
which were available on that
so they upload the keylogger they
obtained the credentials
then they logged onto the system they
installed the malware
they scanned the entire network they got
access to the uh
administrators desktops from
administrator desktops it was
like everything was raining from a
credential standpoint they had access to
oracle databases they had access to the
sftp
they got access to whatnot information
that we can think of
and uh unfortunately uh you know this
organization
was in the payments so they they already
they they were kind of uh invested
heavily by the payment processors as
well
so they they were penalized by the rbi
they got investigated by the third india
as well
uh the the total amount that they kind
of uh
put into the penalties and the fines was
to the tunes of 25 crores
indian rupee and not only that i have
seen the ceo sitting in front of the rbi
governor holding hands and saying
sorry and taking apology for not taking
a new care
on on the incident and on the issues
that has been raised
to buy the team uh to the leadership
earlier
so yeah the the threats are real the the
impact are dreadful
and where it all starts is the
configuration
issues the people not being aware on the
basics
so yeah i totally agree with you sharmak
on that
so cyber security is no more a threat
that impacts only i.t
the previously ideal rather a part or
enabler of the business but now
businesses are i.t
itself previously it used to be said
that business is run on it
businesses are supported by it but now
you have businesses
which are i.t itself which are id
centric business
look at the look at the growth the
fintech sector has seen okay the fintech
is totally uh industrial industry which
is
thriving on technology right it's
underground with the technology
here technology is the mother of the
mother of the
business mother of the solution so when
technology is such an
important part of the business you can't
have an impact you can't have
i mean these impacted cyber security is
definitely going to resonate across your
entire business
and now more and more industries are
being regulated by industry regularly by
the regulators microfigures like try
sab rbi whatever you have in india or
whatever across the world
so regulations are becoming stronger
because of the impact on share price
because the impact on shareholders
okay so because of that and this could
lead to in turn to a lot of market scams
so that is why regulators are becoming
stronger so overall that is why
cyber security protection is becoming
more and more important
and more so i think xiaomi it's it's not
about the information
uh nowadays it's about an individual
life as well
so consider a breach which happens
within a healthcare system
and you are being operated by a robot
and that robot is under a threat and
and under a breach so i mean consider
the impact that it can have
on the individual life as well so yeah i
mean
it's it's everywhere you can't really
think about an industry which is immune
to it and
uh i mean it's the threat is not only
the information it's beyond boundaries
beyond our imagination
and beyond anything else is what i can
see
i i'd like to yeah amplify on that there
was a
recent incident in germany where
a hospital's emergency room was hacked
it wasn't necessarily clinical
procedures that were being hacked into
but the
problem created uh a closure of the
emergency room people actually had to
stop getting treatment because of the
attack
and the way you've described
the threats and the
responses is very much
in the language of warfare i mean you
have
propaganda operations you have
uh spying operations you have
an arms race it's uh
it's really as pointed out
since we live in an information world
now
since uh many of the of the businesses
and jobs we have
are purely on the information platform
this is a super critical
challenge for the world
for governments for businesses for
individuals
what has coveted done to this we were in
the middle of
uh an ongoing pandemic we have
countries that are experiencing second
and third waves of infection
lockdowns uh being imposed
released and then reimposed um
and how has that changed both the way
we uh interact with information systems
but also
the the cyber security threats
so you're asking that how what are the
changes that have brought about right
that is a practical question
so companies are organizations which are
more digitally resilient we have seen
that
they have been left impacted by the
provider okay
so in in kobe during postpo times what
we have seen
is a lot of uh email compromises
which are again as part of the saying uh
they are based on
uh phishing the first image compromised
email
and they are using the very basic
tendency or the weakness of human beings
to fall in for
uh weaknesses right so in govi time we
have seen the people are
definitely they are craving for more
useful information
health information health topics uh
medical information things like that so
definitely
uh fishing information has been on the
rise efficiently it has been on the rise
in both probably times
but companies which were always
resilient they have shown
that they can fight with the situation
much better than
than companies which have not been
prepared like that
in kovid or rather than post coverage
employees have moved to the
or to the home right so uh they are all
working from home they are all logging
from the outside their parameter
companies parameters the company log
into the company
vpn so internet export applications they
are taking the major load right now
okay so companies which had exposed most
of the applications
adequate security now can cater to the
increased demand
companies which had uh now employees are
always using
digital collaboration tools like webex
and all the room and all of this stuff
the companies which are always already
into the platform
now uh they they are saying that they
can keep up with the situation better
but for an individual i think apple for
an individual for an employee i think
the change is not too much except that
he's working from home
except that he's getting used to a
different or a new kind of working
atmosphere okay which he has never done
before
but for companies uh there has been a
lot of change and mainly
in the work environment and how they
cope up with the digital
digital digital threats
and and just to add to that uh marketing
if you really look at uh today's
incident or a couple of days
before if you really go while we talk
about the cyber it it always kind of
revolves around
the triad of a confidentiality integrity
and availability i mean from a basic
standpoint
and the way we look at the situation
right now in hyderabad in india
it's raining it's flooding and because
of that
we have seen that the organizations are
not able to
support or operate their business and
for the simple reason that the isps are
down
people who are working from home they do
not have an electricity to
really charge up their laptops or the
mobile phone
i mean it it can it can get really worse
it can really turn the businesses out of
shape
it can really impact the revenues as
well now
this is just one instance from a work
from home perspective the other
consideration you should
look at earlier when we used to work
from offices
and i'm sure we all missed that but
earlier when we used to work from office
facility we used to have a secure
network we used to have a secure
communication media
we used to have an access control passes
to really enter into the facility and
then operate from there
today when we work from our our own
kind of offices within our homes we
don't
see that happening we have our wireless
configured within our home network
with the range which is accessible to
the people even in the other towers as
well
so we see that a thread of wireless
hacking or man in the middle
as something which can really happen to
anyone and everyone now
you talked about the simple email
attacks
and that is absolutely uh the right
example that you took
i think that is something which is being
targeted now in the wild as well
other than that if you really see we
have
so many people accessing our home now we
we can really party together while we
are
we are working from home and we are
really not sure of the attack that we
can go
under with our corporate assets sitting
there and probably unlocked
for some of the times i mean these these
are some basics that i have seen and i
have been
practicing to avoid the breaches at our
home
the other threat if you really get into
a complexity
the other thread that we see from a work
from home perspective
is uh the data exfiltration
i mean if you really do not have a vpn
or a channel encryption and you are
accessing your corporate resources over
the internet
you do not have a visibility into the
individual's network
anybody can really tap in create a
shared drive
onto their local network can copy the
data
i mean that's that's all that they can
do you
you put up a proxy server at your home
and you monitor all the credentials
going out
and that could be it you you could have
an entry point into the corporate
environment as well
so i mean the work from home really have
changed the way we need to really look
at security
and not only from the technology
standpoint but also from a cultural
standpoint
it has all the more become important to
educate people
to gamify the learning i mean we have to
break our barriers to come out of
that simple presentation done more to
make sure that it becomes interesting
for people to understand and to absorb
those
concepts really well so that they can
really rely those uh
or kind of replay those examples in
their real life
and then see whether it kind of
propagates to their children as well i
mean so
yeah the work from home culture has
really turned things upside down
so exactly for us one more learning or
one more lesson for the company
is that there is nothing called a
corporate asset anymore so everything is
a corporate asset
wherever companies data is being
transmitted used encrypted decrypted
uh passed stored whatever whatever the
lifecycle of the data be
that is an appropriate asset and
requires an adjustment
and equal amount of protection just any
area any other traditional corporate
asset
so employees are not maybe may not be
using their company laptop they could be
using their company
sorry their personal devices sharing
their personal wi-fi network
and other and if access can get into the
network
author smart devices my maybe my
refrigerator my smart tv
is also connected to my network my home
network and if my people's bad guys
enter the network and then get into my
laptop so back it's gone
so so endpoint computing so computing
security at the end point at the brink
at the very very has become even more
important today
with the workshop home scenario that is
so we've reviewed the current status of
the cyber security environment the
threats we've talked about
how covet has changed how we work and
therefore
how many vulnerabilities we've opened up
what does all of this mean for cyber
security professionals
how are careers going to be changed and
what skills
should people be looking to emphasize
in the future i will take this question
for us will do approval from you first
previously it was easier to define to
give an answer to this question
because cyber security was a much
smaller field seven years back ten years
back
now you have got so much of domains of
the cyber security so it definitely
whenever someone comes up with the
question said i want to get into cyber
security
i will ask i will laugh it off and think
that this domain of everything they want
to get into
i know that's not a very right answer
because the person who is asking may not
have the
may not have uh the the perception or
the
requisite amount of inputs actually to
make the decision at the point of time
but cyber security is huge right now
okay but i will always go by instinct so
i started my career as
a fm facility management engineer and i
knew nothing of cyber security
so i was fresh out of college had read
networking by tannenbaum
in computer science or in electronics
and telecommunications
that was my closest shape with
networking networking rather
and based on the knowledge i was
interviewed and was became and became a
facility management engineer
at a public services company and i was
asked by my employer to take care of the
firewall
so i mean so nothing so first of all i
did not know network security i did not
know
did secure nothing at that point of time
but what i i just followed instinct
i just did my job so whatever i was
asked to i didn't try to
learn from magita from internet for
various other point of time there was
not too much of internet there was not
too much of
information so much if available on
internet but remember
i used to have the checkpoint there was
a checkpoint firewall 4.1 that was the
date of 4.1
and checkpoint needs to have their huge
fat in fat
release notes okay so this wasn't
satisfactory
so i used that was the only book i had
that was my only reference i had at the
point of time
so i just went by instinct learned up
what was told to me what was given to me
and gradually my career progressed so it
started with network equity for two and
a half years
then got a job in one of the big four
while starting professional services
so that is how my career took the turn
so then i saw the professional services
indeed a big
part of security so gradually as and
when i got
opportunities i my cyber security area
changed
so my advice to all is that don't try
to approve things whatever you get learn
it
use it learn it more and use it as a
platform to move on to the next
next uh chair okay you don't have to
forcefully move into cloud you don't
have to forcefully move into it
so whatever is there everything has got
a potential for you to learn and improve
so just use the platform whatever you
have that is my basic
i can give more advice later on
i agree sean mc and i think the way i
look at it is exactly the same
and uh you know when we started i think
our career
there was no concept of cyber security
there was a concept of
idp right and i.t only right
and i remember when i started there was
a boom in java programming and
everybody was behind java coding
creating programs and whatnot
and eventually that kind of
made a shift towards uh it configuration
then made a shift towards an id security
and that's where
firewalls network security started to
to see their view into the age and
eventually when it all grew it became
and rather it took a shape of
information security where there was an
era of
information sharing there was an era of
information collection so
it took a shape of information security
from a compliance standpoint from a
regulatory standpoint the regulator
started to be more
vigilant more agile and then we saw an
era where everything started to
kind of go back to the traditional i.t
security and
become more more deadly i would say
or more dangerous uh and that's where it
took a shape of cyber security
now if you really see a cyber that's a
portion of information security the way
i see it
wherein it talks more in terms of
technology in terms of
configurations in terms of the
indicators of compromise consuming the
threats
set indicators uh doing a threat
profiling
and what not so i think from a cyber
security standpoint like show much said
uh i mean there is nothing that you can
really predict
in the cyber today we are talking about
cloud probably tomorrow we are talking
about some new other concepts
right so don't force yourself into one
particular area is what my
piece of advice is but rather my
suggestion is to learn
technology first of all because until
unless you know
what you're protecting you would not be
able to protect it
so understand the security uh from the
perspective of protecting the i.t
now for a very very basic example if we
really need to protect a web server we
should first understand how a web server
works
what are the different communication
protocols which are available
for a web communication what are the
different codes
from a request and a response standpoint
that that a client and a server
interacts with so until unless we
understand that nitty-gritty of
how web server works we would not be
able to do justice to the domain itself
what we will do rather is probably
create a policy
create some superficial rules and then
believe in a myth
that everything is secured because i
have done my piece of job
which is not true to a reality
so from that perspective my belief very
strong belief rather is
is to get your ground first of all
covered on the technology so if somebody
wants to let's say
take up a area of cloud security i would
say first go
and get your hands dirty on the cloud
first of all understanding how cloud
interacts how the cloud
really works and then you can really
talk about the security and same thing
goes for application security for
instance or mobile security
for that matter or a network security
for that matter you really need to know
the technology before you get your
controls covered up for uh the threats
that you're going to protect against so
that's how i see it
right when i'm thinking or listening to
that i'm thinking of
a race car driver
and a race car driver is not the same as
a
casual automobile user who is a user of
the technology but doesn't necessarily
understand how it works
the race car driver typically has
mechanical background and understands
everything that's going on
in every system in that vehicle so that
as he's
traveling at 180 miles an hour he can
tell what vibration means
what a particular sound tells him about
the system
and understanding the internals
gives him the the ability of
diagnosing any kinds of issues or
problems that might come up that could
take them off the road or kill them so
it's
something similar here where we're
talking as you're describing
both being able to be generally
adaptable in understanding technology
but also
understanding the internals of the
technology
that you're trying to protect so that's
a
very good advice um
sound like you were you're going to say
something
uh i couldn't i didn't get lost for
today
i asked if you were going to add more to
what the
process said okay yeah definitely i can
add something more
so these days we see a lot of people who
are thinking of taking up a career in
cyber facility by just doing a quotes
okay or maybe a certification okay so i
would say while that is one of the
important things that you should do
certification definitely adds but it
adds
on to knowledge and it adds up to
experience okay
only certification only i don't
even go a long distance definitely what
counts first is knowledge and then what
counts next is experience
certification is the complement of that
certification is a testimony of that
right so get you as far as get your
hands dirty whatever you get
don't be choosy my my my advice for
every youngster would be
don't be juicy don't just go by the fad
in the town that okay cloud security is
hot
iot is hot mobile is hot okay social is
hot
i'll go by that and that will give me
more jobs the moment you
are running for a job uh while trying to
define cyber security career
you have changed your objectives so
don't let a job
define your career uh with what is
required define a period
jobs will automatically fall in place so
as far as said
learn technology first learn operating
system first
learn devices first and accordingly the
complete picture of cyber security that
all the missing pictures will gradually
come together
and give you a complete picture then it
can be plowed today it can be something
else tomorrow it can be rain tomorrow it
can be whatever
all of these things will gradually fall
in stage and you can take it up
so one more important thing is that
staying relevant
cyber security is so changing i mean the
technology that's not changing
so how do you remain relevant over a
career spanning
20 years 25 years a year that is also
important that those
challenge okay you cannot go out of
relevance
so a technology should not define your
relevance
a particular technology should not
define who you are
that i am good at this and the moment
the technology is gone
do i lose my job no if you have a basics
right if you have the knowledge right
if you see the whole picture properly at
the same time
then i think you still remain relevant
for ages to come and as long as
you have your career i think that's how
i just wanted to pick the class to the
crowd over
so i believe that i i know how you're
going to answer this but
in both of your cases you
look for people to join your teams and
evaluate them and hire them
um and what what types of people are you
looking for in terms of
their aptitude their interests and their
backgrounds
to join your your cyber security efforts
for me it's attitude that you should
achieve okay so knowledge may
i mean this guy may be knowledgeable
tomorrow on something a new technology
he may not have the necessary knowledge
so knowledge is not very important today
it's important but
knowledge can be acquired so you are not
born with the knowledge
you have to acquire knowledge so
whatever knowledge that you are working
on is not something that we are
born with okay we have all acquired this
knowledge over time
and so as in when you start i believe if
you have the attitude you'll
acquire the knowledge so what is more
important attitude attitude to learn
the attitude to remain humble okay and
the attitude
to fight it out irrespective for the
odds
so you might see often that someone is
getting more money in a
in certain part of in certain different
careers
okay he's getting a different maybe a
plusher job or something like that
that should not demotivate you okay you
remain focused on knowledge
and uh you remain focused and your
attitude will drive you
to get more knowledge and as and when
the right job will
fall on your lap something like that for
us what are your thoughts
i totally agree with you sharmak and i
think uh
when we talk about attitude it's all
about being proactive
you talked about being relevant uh it's
it's always about never lose hope and
the moment i see anybody joining my team
uh i basically look at obviously the
attitude is one but then
i also look at some of the complementing
areas
and that's that is something which many
people really doesn't focus upon
unfortunately
and a that is awareness
on the latest trends on what is
happening within the technology
and if you are appearing for an
interview let's say for an organization
for a profile what awareness you have
for that particular role
so i think that clarity of a role is
very important when it comes to
a job interview or landing into a job
because that will
that will decide how your future really
shapes up that is one
second uh area where i see people really
uh
faltering upon is is honestly taking
their job seriously
and they they probably would be not very
well prepared
and when i say prepare it's not
technical preparation but rather
from a soft skills preparation
perspective
they would appear so casual in an
interview that
it doesn't really define their
seriousness it can be an
uh it can be unbiased as well in me uh
you know please forgive me for that
but the way i see is if you really don't
worship your job if you are really not
up for
what you're preparing for uh you would
really not
honor that and when i say soft skills
uh it's very basic to really uh
comb up your hairs uh be presentful
uh and then be available for
the time slot that you have been slotted
for so
if you're not on time i mean that's one
of the
uh turn down for me so and these are
some of the areas that i would look for
and absolutely attitude without goes
up is paramount and that is uh
that is very very important for
parameter for me as well
uh and then knowledge and skills will
follow automatically with an attitude
so i totally conquer with you shamakun
that point
up so yeah these are some additions that
i i would look out for the people
who are really interested in joining uh
joining the teams
all right this is uh it's been a great
discussion i'd like to move on to some
of the questions
from the audience first off uh can you
hear me clearly
engineering or from
service delivery management
into cyber security what advice would
you give somebody
trying to make that type of a career
so the way that i look at from a
transition perspective
i can share my journey where i started
from a health desk it helped desk
as my first job and then transitioning
into a core id from a server management
perspective and then into the security
and there was a very funny reason that i
landed up into a security
is is that i saw one lady being really
pampered upon in
an organization when she stepped in and
she was an auditor
i was a support engineering guy and
i said this is something that i want to
be and
that's where i i kind of focused and
then i landed up in
as well now from an i.t services if
somebody wants to make a transition
into security i think that's i still see
that as very very relevant
because the individual would already
have an experience
of a view onto an i.t landscape that is
one
second the individual would also have
been exposed
to the i.t servicing wherein they would
be interacting with the customers they
would be interacting with their internal
stakeholders as well
the third point is from a transition
perspective
is it's never too late and when you are
into an i.t services kind of kind of an
organization or a profile
you are already talking a language of a
technology
and once you are aware of a technology
like i said earlier it's easier to
protect it
and and you just have to really tune
your thoughts
to think it otherwise to think what can
go wrong
and how it can happen now that's from a
personal tuning perspective and personal
thoughts perspective when it comes to a
job
it is important that first of all you
should have
some experience on the security front if
you really want to table your
profile to a job interview if that is
not a case then you should really have
a substitute in terms of the
certifications
or the trainings that you have taken or
the courses that you have attended
from a cyber security standpoint because
that adds
to a proactiveness like i talked about
that you're proactive in upskilling
yourself and making sure that you're
relevant to the industry
so either you should have an experience
or you should have a willingness to
learn and you should have done
some courses certifications attended
universities
in that area before you land your resume
for a job
and then it is all about your confidence
it is all about how you convince
the interviewer on the other side people
today i can tell you within the
organizations are
okay to accept the transitions as well
i have seen that happening in pwc i i
can see that happening
in microsoft as well for that matter
people are okay to
to consider a transition candidate till
the time
the person is really showing that keen
interest
into the domain and they have proven
their knowledge
uh in in a discussion so it's all about
how you take it
and uh industry is really accepting it i
don't see any uh
any issues in that uh i'll just add on
to what parents say
mahesh i guess this question is from you
so i'll read out what you said
i am a i.t service delivery manager
managing operations how to transition to
security
and it has become paramount for
operations what will start with and what
should be relevant
okay i'll give you one or two pointers
since operations must be an uh working
on an itsm tool
right nowadays we have these tools which
are combined with grc
itsm tool from grc combined so there is
a manager of ip7 grc
because grc tool as you know what does
it do
it takes uh incidents from you it takes
influence from you
it takes audit reports from you it takes
observation finding from you
creates a race and then tries to create
and work slow based on which you can
you can have visibility on the life
cycle of the trace
till it is addressed mitigated whatever
okay so
most of these come from iit service uh
requests or maybe i t service inside
incidents
right so that is of its sm tool and grc
booth have happened
and there are quite some tools
commercially available in the market i
will not name them
which have a single interview for both
right and that may be that's also a
reason why they're selling more than
some other tools so that is something
which you can look at
because that will also give you a
hands-on experience on managing a grc
tool also
if you do that i'm being a little more
specific as part of it service delivery
you would you could might
you could also possibly be looking at
i.t
incident and a part of that would be i t
secured incidents
i am not sure how it works in your
organization but you could be working
items that
secure incidents so try to understand
how the iit security incidents or events
are being
addressed so there is a whole chapter in
ii security and i t security incident
management
and i t secured insuring the disruption
okay of our business video situation
due to security or whatever okay because
of one of the three cia being not
present one or more try to understand
how that incident is being addressed so
instead of being just a manager
looking at the mis and looking at
closure of incidents try to be more
specific and detail and hands-on
into iep secret incidents maybe you will
find a lot of threats which will be
coming in a lot of things which are
resulting into
a resulting attack which are coming up
with incidents
uh in terms of in terms of symptoms i
mean the incidence first comes to you
in the form of a symptom that is how the
investigation leads to the discovery of
a threat or an attack in the company
so you could also focus on there so i
just wanted to add these two points
excellent um we have a number of
freshers in the audience and uh i have
one interesting question here from
lakshmi
which is specific to the indian market
which is you know how are state
governmental and non-governmental
colleges
equally valuable in
studying technology and cyber security
um she asks if somebody needs to move
into an urban area to take this training
or are more provincial
colleges capable of giving that kind of
education
come back i see you're you're looking
you're thinking about that answer
that's uh that's a little typical that's
a little
weird question to our answer uh
which is better i think that's the
question the state government
institutions
or the private institutions right so i
i'm not exactly sure who should be
better but most of the institutions
they draw the inspiration or they their
courses are defined
in collaboration with uh mostly large
universities
okay who have uh who have famous uh i
mean who have pioneered the cause of
cyber security
so if that's a common source so i don't
think there could be too much of a
difference
maybe the economics will change maybe
the mode of execution will change
okay but uh i think uh
the private university of the private
college and the private institution
which surveys the government one did not
matter too much
as long as you have the required
knowledge along with attitude i think
you can sail through
so to answer your question i really
don't want in the voting
comparison but i think both are equally
good but
uh what will sail you through what will
take you through
is you i mean that is you right what you
are what you are made of
so whatever be the knowledge that is
coming from any of your courses
whatever you add on top of it is what
you are that is how i will put it
yeah and and just as a principle of
guidance uh
on selecting uh probably either offer
i would say uh try to verify what kind
of a lab facility they
they offer what timings do they offer
whether you are allowed to access a lab
after a particular point in time or not
so that once your class gets over you
are allowed to enter the lab and
practice yourself
out in the lab so that is one important
thing
the second thing is uh look at the
course
curriculum as an outline and see whether
it relates to your thoughts as well
i mean don't really push yourself into a
course which you
really don't understand so first of all
it is important to understand the course
outline and if you believe that that is
something which is going to help you
i i would say go for it the third thing
that i see
is uh look at the course outline
try to map that out with a
certifications which are available
in the industry as well and see if after
completing the course
would it enable you to take up specific
certification so that you don't end up
spending a lot of money on on the
certification learning cost as well
so i would say look at for these three
aspects
and if you believe that all the three
areas are okay
uh it really doesn't matter like shomak
said whether it's a government base or
a private player it really uh it is it's
really about getting your hands dirty
and how much time you really spend
on learning the new areas of the
knowledge
i'd also like to ask a question related
to what you had said about knowing
the technology is there a particular
priority that somebody should look at
for which technology to know
should it be web servers versus cloud
versus um
you know some other aspect
what where would you recommend people to
start or is there any
preference so i honestly do not have any
preference on that
but there are multiple areas that one
can really evangelize and
get their career developed into for
instance
we can really learn the operating system
from a windows standpoint
and become either ethical hacker
on the operating system platform or we
can also
look at growing ourselves into a cyber
forensics for microsoft windows platform
same thing we can go for a linux
administration
or understanding linux course and then
growing ourselves into the field of
ethical hackers
bug bounties or even the forensic side
on the application side if i'm a
developer if i
if i learn one language out of many i
know the concepts of
application development and and later on
i can see myself going into an
application security area
if i'm good at really compliant side of
it
i can look out myself for growing into
an area of a risk management or a risk
assessment
so i mean there are multiple areas so if
we are working on a network side
i can grow myself into a threat hunting
i can grow myself into security
operation center
and so on so it totally depends on what
area you are currently working upon
what excites you and you will have your
career in the cyber security because it
cut across
each and every technology that we touch
today
yeah so this goes back to what i said
earlier don't try to change what you are
doing
okay be where you are if your network
security if you're into waste
administration if you're into device
management
if you're into something else okay
continue to do what you are
you will always find that security uh
its uh security can be added completely
on top of that
so learn security in your field and
gradually think with volume page
so you don't have to forcefully change
just because you think that the carrier
is better over there
but yes some things are doing good
because the companies are moving to a
borderless
environment where local data centers are
physical light infrastructure is
becoming more and more
less relevant okay so that is quite
cloudy that is why you see more
more happening more hot they stay okay
and cloud is going to stay
and stay for long okay so you gradually
see the decadence
of the typical traditional edp or the
data center
companies will not invest more in
writing just with the clean plates
and all the stuff okay so computing
storage
everything networking everything moves
the cloud okay so that's a cloud is
going to be
the technology of the future so you can
definitely uh
definitely what that look at the cloud
or the possibility option
but when you are walking in the cloud
everything remains same cloud is at the
end of the day
a large data center right so when you
move to the cloud when you go as an
engineer when you become an engineer
with a cloud service provider
you're basically working in a large data
center much larger
much more resilient much more
geographically spread data center so at
the end of the
data center okay whatever it is or
whatever it's scattered
or whatever it is so the basic
technologies still hold good
whatever you have learned remain very
warm and try to learn over there
next um i have one last question to get
from mahesh
which i think is an interesting question
because it
deals with a buzzword that we keep
hearing
um devops which
is an important aspect of
cloud software development deployment
but
how does that relate to cyber security
and cyber cyber secops and that type of
thing
are do you see those as
uh real
areas of interest or right now
buzzwords that describe other real work
i think parents can go for this i mean
i can take that question um as well so
uh
from a devops standpoint uh
you know the way i look at so consider
an environment i'll take an example
i am let's say following a waterfall
model uh within the
software development i first of all go
to all the business teams all the
stakeholders
bas and i will start collecting the
requirements
now in the middle of a project let's
assume the technology have changed
or the business requirements have
changed i have already developed a piece
of code
which is not yet tested and
i have to really circle back go back to
the initial phase again and then
start to collect the requirements again
from the security standpoint from the
technology standpoint from the business
standpoint
and i will keep doing that till the time
my final output is ready
now this is this is still easy to manage
look at a different situation where i
have got
my code almost ready it is not
uh it is it is ready for the deployment
and the security team comes and says hey
what
this is something which cannot go live
because because it has
so many bugs in this and these are the
security flaws you can't really launch
the product with this so you will have
to repeat the cycle again because you
missed
taking the inputs from the security team
initially or the regulations have
changed in the midway
and you are forced to take those
decisions again
now that is where i see a devops
partnering it with the security and
driving it all together you today
in today's environment you don't really
code in a waterfall model you rather go
agile
and that is where you keep on involving
the stakeholders at different spaces
making sure that they are being heard
their requirements are being listened to
and are being accommodated within the
code that you are developing
at any point in time that you see that
the requirements have changed you have a
flexibility to really
fix that issue in a real time now that's
on a project management standpoint from
an agility
perspective from a security standpoint
you have your agile team ready
who is really taking up the challenges
of doing a code testing in a real time
you can either automate that you can
have your teams on a standby to do that
testing for you
within a defined period of time so that
you can budget that within your code
changes
and the moment you have a code ready you
already have your stakeholders involved
so your security teams are aware
that this is something which is
happening this is a language this is a
platform
these are the lines of codes which are
being written and the code is made
available to the security team
beforehand for the testing and you don't
really land up in the surprises at the
end
where you are you are into an unaware
kind of a zone from a security bugs
perspective
so i see that secured secure devops
uh is it's a real concept uh
it is really helping many organizations
as we speak today
uh there are various uh tools available
wherein
the developer doesn't have to go to a
security team altogether
uh you just have to as a developer you
just have to submit a code
into an application and the application
run itself
provides you as a developer a view in
terms of the security weaknesses
from an automated scanning perspective
you as a developer go back and fix those
issues before you share that code with
the security team so you cut down
on your maintenance cost you cut down on
your
on your operation cycle you cut down on
the surprises
and obviously you cut down on the threat
surface
from a production code perspective and
then the security teams
are really tasked to give a final view
on the security from a penetration
testing black box gray box or a white
box
to present you a view from a business
stakeholder whether the application is
secure and bug free from a security
issues or not
so you really kind of integrate your
process
from a security team and
and you get the output that you are
intending without any surprises at the
end
so yeah secure devops is a good concept
and it is here to stay as well
and the primary reason behind everything
has been the agility of the business the
business needs to be more agile
yes from their expected in their
expectations from the it department for
the computer application
other digital applications that they
want from department and since they
can't afford too much of time
these guys have to make a decision and
that is when all devops take development
yeah gentlemen thank you very much for
being with us today this has been a
really wonderful
uh discussion and i hope that our uh
audience
has found it valuable as well
and i want to thank both
for us they have uh
linkedin links you can find them there
if you would like to
um connect with them
and we have so many more questions than
we could possibly fit into the
time allotted so we will be doing some
follow-up articles
uh on the subject
i would also like to thank our partner
freshers world
for promoting the webinar and
precious world is the number one general
job portal for freshers in india
so we really thank them for being a
partner with us today
i do want to mention our next
upcoming webinar uh in the
topic of itil and how itil
uh combines with digital transformation
and helps it provide greater value to
businesses
it's another interesting career field
and our expert
speaker will be akshay anand there's a
product advantage with
axelos that will be
next wednesday one week
and i want to thank everybody
invite you all to connect with us uh
our simply learned social channels
facebook twitter and linkedin
this is the conclusion of our webinar
so again thank you to our panelists and
thank you to our audience and we look
forward to seeing you at future webinars
thank you simply learn thank you the
audience we had and it was great having
you all here and look forward to
more such engagements in the future
thank you
absolutely thank you everyone and stay
safe and stay secure as well
right thank you
[Music]
you